Good morning Hank, it's Wednesday.
So last week was one of the worst weeks of
my life: Henry was really super-sick and we
were very scared and also he was crying all
night every night so we were staying up all
night and it was just ... misery.
Plus I was worried the Project for Awesome
wouldn't raise any money and the website would
break and it would be a total failure and
all of nerdfighteria would hate us and exile
us to the island of Elba.
Like you know how the world's largest ball
of stamps is in Omaha, Nebraska? Well, last
week it felt like the world's largest ball
of suck was here, at my house.
But then things startet to change. First and
most importantly, Henry got better. Then the
Project for Awesome generated more than 3,000
P4A videos and raised more than 135,000 $. It
probably raised much more than that, but that's
how much we can confirm. I mean, Hank, I'm
pretty sure that 135,000 $ is a lot of money,
although admittedly I'm not a mathematician.
I have an idea. I'm calling Brotherhood 2.0
Resident Mathematician and State Representative
of elect Daniel Biss. (on the phone) So here's
what I wanna ask today: In your opinion as
a professional mathematician who has been
published in the annals of mathematics, is
135,000 $ a lot of money? (after Daniel said
"Yes") Yes! We did it!
So we raised a lot of money and then, then,
then, I was on Jeopardy. So made-of-awesome
nerdfighter librarian named Julia Carlis was
on Jeopardy yesterday and she did not know
the question for final Jeopardy. So calmly
and confidently she wrote on her little tablet:
"Who is John Green?" as a subtle shout-out
to nerdfighteria. Which, in turn, Hank, led
to Alex Trebek uttering the immortal words:
"John Green, that's gonna cost you!" Julia
Carlis, I'm sorry that you lost on Jeopardy,
but thank you for making my life. And the
good news is: You win the non-existent nerdfighter-prize
of the day, which isn't nothing. Actually,
it is nothing.
Nerdfighters, thank you for making P4A videos,
for donating, for commenting, for making Alex
Trebek say my name on television.
Hank, my week has taken such a turn that I
can only share with you my happy dance as
coached by wheezywaiter.
Wheezywaiter: Keep dancing; don't stop.
John: This is going to be hard.
Wheezywaiter: Whoa! That wasn't very good.
That's good; you're doing good. Keep it up!
You're doing well. Keep it up. There you go.
John: I'll meet you guys downstairs.
Wheezy: That's right, keep it up. You can
do it.
John: And now, for my grand finale, a handstand!
Wheezy: Ahh, that about does it. Boy, am I
tired from all the dancing.
So Hank, on Dec 26th we're gonna draw the
raffles, eh, I've got to finish my Zombie
Apocalypse Novella, but I'm on it. Hank, I
will not see you on Friday, because it's Christmas
Eve, but have a wonderful holiday and I will
see you again on Monday.